hello everyone and welcome back to the
semifinals of the world Fisher random
championship we've already covered the
games between Magnus and the Fabiano
Coulson proceeds to the finals and one
of these two gentlemen will be his
opponent so here's a game
it's from the rapid section this is the
second game of the rapids and it's well
it's just a real roller coaster so I'm
sure you're going to enjoy it without
further ado let's check it out it's the
same position we've covered in both
games both of the rapid games between
cross and Korra wanna you know the one
where it's very easy to develop your
bishops so let's see how Wesley and the
NIP will do it will be three already
developing well not developing but
opening up the dark square Bishop with
b6 napadas the same we have c4 and
Knight to c6 III and already on move
three nipple play swith the night so
what's the idea the idea is that it's
not all that easy to kick it away you
don't I mean you haven't played this
position ever so you don't know if a3 is
useful we don't want to spend all that
much time on a3 on the other hand if you
play something like this you might even
get check me the knight to d3 is made so
there are some dangers if you don't want
to waste a move to kick it away you have
to be careful so Wesley plays Bishop the
c3 just you know threatens to to remove
it and now II six the Queen guards the
night and before we have Quinta e 2 and
now g5 there is really no merit
tonight the c2 chair because the King
will just move to f1 and then the knight
will well you're just gonna have to go
back to before you don't really have any
useful ideas over there
so g5 opening up the dark square bishop
now Bishop captures on a traitor rook
captures and here Wesley castles we look
back to g8 by Neto and now Knight to c3
continuing development with g4 and g3
now we have Bishop captures an h1
trading off old all of the bishops but
it is something that you might have
expected as all of the bishops are
eyeing each other from from the
from the start of the game so King
captures on each one and now h5 so here
nepo is preparing hh4 maybe maybe
capturing and it's interesting why he
moved the rook over to g8 why not leave
the rook to h8 but I'm sure there was a
good reason the for Wesley continuous
development expands in the center and
now h4 we have b5 by Wesley says your
attack on the Kings side it doesn't
really do anything with Queen to h6 and
E for now we have Knight to d6 and a3
kicking the knight back we have ninth to
a6 and here b4 just slowly developing on
the Queen side saying that this is this
is a weird night here this guy here also
not doing all that great so if your
attack on the King side doesn't work out
your you're gonna have some problems
so rook the h8 now neppo brings the
route back to the h8 square from where
it came from and then now rook the d4
here if you capture on g4 Westley could
go for this but then after characters
and captures you're gonna get Queen side
castles this rook is now coming to g8
also you're the c4 pawn is a weakness so
not something Westar wants to do he
first plays rook to d4 he guards the c4
pawn so now the queen is able to capture
on g4 but c5 an apple says okay either I
ruin your pawn structure or get to that
rook away from there so Wesley decides
to capture D captures and C sticks on
pass on deke actress and now rook F to
d1
nicely doubling up on the D file
preparing rook captures and d6 so H
capture sin g3 now threatening mate and
now F captures and g3
it's very important than the coup that
the queen is covering the h2 square and
you don't have a way of deflecting the
Queen at least not for the moment so
King is 7
you need to defend the knight twice
Knight the b3 now we have c5 rogue back
to d2 and now see characters on b4 with
a capture some before and the Knight
captures on b4 Knight d4 by Wesley and
now already it's an excellent square for
the knight this night has to be careful
you don't want a long night the c6 check
also there might be some ideas
tonight's the f5 check not not for the
moment but you know if if such and such
a position arises so with a five by
napalm he has a past pond so he starts
pushing it and now you can't go neither
five just yet yes it's a check you fork
the Queen but black will not capture
with the pawn black will capture with
the night and then you just don't really
have anything it captures so you're
gonna trade one one of the rooks and
then get the other look over to d8 and
you just help the black consolidate his
position so here Wesley plays the very
interesting Knights eb-5 threatens to
capture here and now basically
deflecting this night so we have night
capture son b5 by nipple and now Knight
to f5 so now we have to capture with a
pawn otherwise you're gonna lose the
Queen we have eight captures and i5e
captures an f5 with Czech opening up a
discovery here King to f6 and now rook
captures and e8 with rook captures and
look out for Sandy a so here Wesley has
a rook for two nights
so Knepper is definitely better here I
mean better material wise he has two
nights for a rook and he has a past a
pawn the problem is his King it's a it's
a very loose King and you have to be
very careful what you do here Queen the
c1 check by Napo King to g2 and now
Knight back to c6
forcing the rotary to move away rook to
d7 and now Knight B to D for now the
Knights are nicely protected and the
queen is under attack here but as usual
two nights ago during each other that's
well it's almost always an issue so look
the d6 check by Wesley pushing the King
back and here's where it gets really
interesting here nipple was extremely
low on time and he has to go King to g5
he he should use the F pawn as a shield
he shouldn't capture it for example King
g5 and now white doesn't really have a
good way of continuing this attack the
best white has is Queen to f2 so it
threatens just to pick up the night and
then when the two nights for a rook but
here black has a four that's the point
you have to start pushing your passport
and here after everything gets traded
captures captures captures you will go
Queen to c2 check
kingi one now queen bee one check King
goes back to if you go to g2 then you
can just repeat and start pushing your
pawn or if you go somewhere like King to
f2 then you can even pick up this pawn
with check and now it's a queen and pawn
end game where black is up upon but it's
a very very strong past a pawn
so this is the best Burnett before
nipple King to g5
however he played King captures on f5
and now Wesley goes rook to d5 check
otherwise if the exponent was still here
if the King was in g5 black could have
used the f5 point as a shield but okay
King of six will rope the d6 check King
to g5 and now Queen to f2 with a similar
idea you just want to give up the rook
for two nights
so Knight to f3 just getting the night
into the attack hoping for rook captures
and c6 and then Quinta II one with check
King to h1 you have to move and now
Knight the d3
I discovered to check also the queen is
under attack you have to go king a queen
g1 and now Knight to f3 check King to g2
and now Quinta III but this is very hard
stuff to find especially when you're
very low on the clock now you don't have
anything better than the capture of the
night Queenie for check and then you
pick up the rook and you enter the
similar endgame or your upper passed a
pawn but after Knight to f3 wesley plays
h4 with check we have G captures on h3
and now with check and King captures on
f3 Wesley grabs the night but his King
is now in a very delicate position
and here again it's it's impossible to
find the correct move here with very
little time on the clock for example you
can't go Queen a3 check to pick up the
rook because Queen III check blocks
check and also delivers check so here
you would have to trade captures
captures and now push a for oh of course
black is better here so that's something
you could play but there are better
moves for example f5 and white doesn't
have a good move here
the the pawn really restricts the
movement of the white king you cannot go
back to g2 and it's just a just a very
tough position for for white you you
don't have a better
then quinta III check and then well you
basically end up in in a similar end
game but here
Napo played h2 instead and it makes
sense you're threatening upon 2 H 1 this
will bring another queen to the game so
it looks perfect the problem is of
course if white captures then Queen III
check that's pick up the rook but upon 2
H 2 allows Wesley rogue d5 check and now
the problem is you will not have Queen
8/3 checked followed by Queen captures
rook because the rook is now on d5 so we
have F 5 by neppo and now Wesley just
captures the HTT p-- on because there's
no check to pick up the rook so we have
nice the d4 check and never again tries
to give up the night for Queens III
check followed by Queen captures rook
but now comes King to g2 we have Queen
to d2 check King to h3 and now Queen
back the e3 we have Queen tabby tuna
with a double attack on the knight on d4
and now Knight the e6 and here rook the
e5 attacking the Queen so what do you
play here here best for Nico is Knight
to f4 check there's no better move than
this one after the king moves king h2
now you create like this 93 attack the
Queen and the rook and you force a trade
like this captures captures and this is
this is a good endgame for you you're
still up upon your threatening to pick
up the c4 pawn if will be three you can
just pick it up and defend your pawn
black black can definitely play this
however Nippo are low on the low on time
played Queen to d4 and now it's a bit
different because Wesley captures we
have Queen captures and Knight captures
and rook the d5 this move makes all the
difference in the world because now the
knight has to move after night the c2 we
have C 5 and the nice point chain on the
Queen side is broken so you don't have a
an option of advancing because then
judge the C pawn is too fast so captures
captures now the knight and the pawn are
under attack
Knights the e3 and now rook captures an
a5 so instead of all of those
opportunities where you could go into an
endgame even though you're down the
exchange being up upon and the very
strong past a pawn here it's equal equal
points so at one point each but it's a
rook against tonight we have Knight to
g4 now
King to g2 and now Knight to f6 so of
course Wesley has more time on the clock
so he will try to push this four away
with King to f3 Knight the g4 looked the
b5 and announ tonight back to f6 we have
looked the b8 King to g6 and now King to
f4 slowly but surely making progress
with the King Knight h5 check we have
King back to f3 and now King to f6 rook
the b5 putting pressure on the pawn here
the King back to g6 and now King to g2
now the King will try to find a way via
the H file we have Knight back to f6
King to h3 Knight to g4 and now King to
h4 so it will not be easy to kick the
White King away from their King f6 now
rugby 6 check King to e5 and now King to
g5 now threatening the threatening check
they'll just pick up the f5 pawn so like
the a3 guarding the pawn here but rooked
f6 now putting black and sort of a Duke
Swank
so what do you play here King Teti
forest was played but it was also on
this move it was moved 60 that young
opponent she resigned the game because
white has a really forced winning
sequence and he had like two seconds on
the clock when he resigned so he was
mostly playing on increment but feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find this very nice forced sequence
since it immediately wins the game well
I give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations on finding such a nice
forcing sequence and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
it's of course rookie six check I know
it's kind of lame where when the you
know solution starts with check but you
know we show what we have so rookie six
check doesn't really matter where the
King goes King anywhere now we pick up
tonight that's the point in character
skin captures on f5 and now your pawn
will just queen and win the game king
here the point is protected and that's
it
so after King to e4 and Apple resigns
and excellent the victory for Wesley so
and in the third game of the rapids they
drew the game and Napo had to win never
had to win all the games to reach the
blitz section otherwise a Western just
has too much
- too many points and they will not be
going into Blitz section much like a
course and in Quran did not go into good
section because crossing 112 and a half
seven and a half where as Wesley takes
the win with 13 to 7 so Wesley will face
Magnus in the finals of the world fish
random championship so it will be very
interesting to see
Wesley has been playing amazing chess he
won seven mattress I believe I believe
it's six or seven matches after neppo to
reach the finals where as Magnus he
automatically qualified into the into
the semi-finals by being sort of at the
unofficial world official random
championship because he defeated Hikaru
Nakamura in the match they had last year
Nadya that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank
Nicholas ionescu Alan :
and Julien you subs are they for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
think of for watching and I will see
soon continuing the finals of the world
fish random championship checking up on
the world the European Team Championship
and of course on your wonderful
suggestions so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day